our next guest who is joining us on the
mercedes-benz vans hotline or phone line
uh is a guy i spent four hours with last
night
a former nfl quarterback analyst for pro
football focus as well as a contributor
to siriusxm nfl radio um nfl quarterback
veteran uh mr bruce gradkowski bruce
what's up buddy good to hear from you
again
hey brother good thanks for having me
and i was gonna say those four hours you
weren't even whining and dining me with
a good meal we were just strictly
talking ball but it definitely was fun i
ran into your guy rich eisen the other
day on the elevator as well he was
looking good i think it's always a great
thing he does every year
running a 40 and i told him i'm looking
forward to that and i don't know why i
get so much
pleasure and satisfaction off of like
someone's discomfort and watching him
run a 40. i just really enjoy that so
i'm looking forward to it again this
year
uh joining us on the phone bruce
grodkowski former nfl quarterback and
now analyst uh so i've been telling the
guys right i mean there's been a lot of
talk this morning around malik willis
and and and and in the hype train and
and you and i i felt like saw it a
little bit similarly yesterday we saw
some quarterbacks struggle a little bit
but kind of talk to us about what you
saw you were there in indianapolis you
watched malik willis uh you saw some of
maybe the the lack of fluidity in some
of his throws he uncorked one of course
65 yards down the field i get that but
but talk to us a little bit about what
you saw last night from the young
quarterback
yeah i mean number one i when i saw him
you know in person the other day i i
went up stood next to him because i
wanted to eye him up and just see
physically how he looked and he's a good
strong looking dude good strong legs um
he's probably you know about six one or
so around my height i might have had him
just by a hair but um
and then you get to the throne and i was
so anxious to watch this part because to
see someone in person that's a lot
different than with pads and in the game
and all that
and and to your point that's a great
point it just
flew it you know it it didn't look fluid
to me it looked like a struggle at times
and the inaccuracy
uh he was off you know he was inaccurate
last night i wanted to see more accuracy
from him but once again you and i you
know we pointed out last night that this
is the first time them ever throwing to
some of these receivers you know and
you're standing in line you're waiting
for the next throw it it's not easy
but you know sometimes you can overthink
things try to be perfect and i think i
saw a little bit of that from him last
night not that i'm overly concerned i
want to look too far deep into that but
yeah it just it just wasn't the night
maybe
i i just would have expected a little
bit more from him and i wanted to see
more because i like him i like his film
i like his athleticism i like he's
strong and can make plays outside the
pocket but i wanted to see better
accuracy more so kind of like
of what we saw from kenny pickett last
night yep that was my next question uh
you know kenny pickett was the butt of
all jokes yesterday right smallest hands
uh
uh in the combine this year at eight and
a half inches right uh nfl network
standing right there next to him he's
not oblivious to what's going on right
the camera's not pointed out of him or
his face it's pointed at his incredibly
tiny hands is the way people are putting
it and then he goes out and puts on a
show right was probably the most
accurate uh he was forceful he had a
good foundation beneath him uh he was
accurate in all phases he let the ball
fly down the football field i just i
thought he did an exceptional job under
the scrutiny and pressure that he had to
deal with uh yesterday because of those
hand measurements
you're spot on i mean you you have a
camera down by your waist like filming
your hand and you know we had an
opportunity to talk to him on nfl radio
this weekend i just loved his poise his
demeanor
even last night you could tell he's a
guy that doesn't get rattled by much
he's got a really kind of smooth
personality about him and he's smooth on
the football field as well i think he's
a football player and a lot of times we
can over we could kind of nitpick things
too much but we can't forget about the
game tape and i asked him the other day
too how did it feel
to be a part of a role change you know
with the fake slide but when i watched
that play
i knew it came natural to him and those
are the type of plays i try to find from
a quarterback to see how instinctive
they are how can they react and just
naturally make a play and that's what he
did in that moment you know he felt like
he was gonna slide but
at the moment he was like wait why i
could keep going and he kept his feet
and end up scoring so i like that part
about him i think he's a football player
i do you know i thought he had a great
night last night i was happy for him
because of
all the the noise surrounding how big
his hands measured uh so for him i'm
happy for him that he had a good night
there is so i still do have some
concerns i mean college football players
they don't play games in december and
january yes they have a bowl game and
whatnot usually it's in indoors or it's
in better weather but december and
january that's when you have to play
your best football in the nfl
so i do have some concerns about maybe
his arm strength and his accuracy
when you're playing in tough
environments weather-wise
but i do really like how he's a football
player and i was glad he had a good
performance last night yeah i was too uh
it was fun to see him overcome something
he can't control right he can't control
the size of his hands right he can go
what he can control is what he did last
night talk to us about some guys that
that piqued your interest that you you
maybe didn't uh necessarily uh
see coming into it but performed
extremely well and i think probably made
themselves some money last night
yeah i mean well i think desmond ritter
just the way he ran like 449 i mean
that's he's moving and that's going to
kind of peak your attention if you're a
scout just knowing oh he's got some
speed to him as well because he he's had
a great college career you know what he
did at cincinnati where he brought that
football team he has a lot of reps under
his belt so that's something to keep an
eye on i think he has to be better as i
watch his tape as being more consistent
be more accurate that's what i'd like to
see from him but i think that 40 is good
it's gonna kind of pique some team's
attention
um you know and then guys down the list
a little bit you know dustin crum you
know a guy from kent state had a
phenomenal career there you know he's a
smart guy he's going to execute the
offense i thought last night he was just
one of those guys that stepped in and
when when it was his turn to throw he
was accurate he completed the ball
and he had good timing and rhythm and he
got back to the back of the line like
he's a guy he didn't say much did his
job and that was it it was but it was it
was spot on it was like the rhythm and
timing you want to see from a
quarterback it was a goal ball over the
shoulder that was perfect
you know twice
right in a row he did it which i thought
was pretty cool you know brock purdy i
thought brock purdy i i was a fan of his
at iowa state because he's tough he
plays the game fun it's fun to watch but
he'd make some like bone-headed
decisions
and i thought that hurt him
later on you know in in his career at
iowa state and it hurt that football
team but i thought last night guess he
did put a good performance on i mean
he's not the biggest guy but he had good
timing and rhythm he was accurate with
the football
he's a guy in later rounds hey he's a
football player if your team needs to
put it back up in he could pray get the
job done and he has to be smarter making
decisions but other than that i thought
he did pretty well
um you know sam howe you know we watched
him i thought you know one side to the
other he threw better
i think it was going to his
left and then when he went to his right
he was just off
um but he's a guy that you know had a
great college career shows he has a good
arm shows he's athletic
but i wanted to see more out of sam
howell last night because
at pff he's our number one uh
quarterback and i'm not sure if you know
i'm on board with that but
i thought last night i wanted to see
more from him
we're speaking with bruce gradkowski pro
football focus analyst as well as
siriusxm radio channel 88 as well um
you listen to me i'm i i really like
carson strong i liked what he was in
college but now he's had two
opportunities the senior bowl and now
the combine at least the throwing aspect
of it and he's looked a little a little
shaken right he he hasn't looked the
part and i've watched him on tape and in
big games and games against better
quality opponents like kansas state and
he is looked
like the the real deal so
what what's your biggest takeaway from
him because he's easily the most
physically talented player at the
quarterback position in this year's nfl
draft oh for sure and you talk about the
amount of reps and throws that he has in
his his college career uh has has been
impressive you know you talking about a
guy you know five big time throws and
zero turnover whether he plays for us at
pfff first colorado state in his final
career game i mean you know that's him
that's what he's capable of doing uh but
you know and that's what i loved about
you last night like you did you were
talking highly of carson strong coming
in
and then you you know one point you did
you're like you know what this is the
second time in a row on a big stage with
the senior boy now the the combine that
he has not stepped up and taken
advantage of that and that's what i saw
last night like for me
you know you and i were talking about it
sometimes as a quarterback you try to
overthink that you try to be perfect and
you aim your throws you try to guide
your throws instead of just taking your
drop and letting that sucker loose you
gotta let it rip
and not overthink it and last night
carson strong looked like he was trying
to be perfect
and just you know pinpoint accurate but
sometimes when you overthink that you
know he threw a couple slants that were
right at the knees he threw an end route
right at the knees
it stinks for him but he'll get another
opportunity his pro day and for a guy
that's just a pocket type passer and
with with the talk around his knee and
and how healthy can he be i think last
night wasn't his best performance yeah
it was it was disappointing especially
for somebody who who thinks he has a
heck of a career uh ahead of him at the
nfl level all right let's uh let's
bounce around the league a little bit um
the quarterback position as always as we
head into free agency as we head into
the new league year is the the
conversation piece you know the biggest
ones out there uh russell wilson and
aaron rodgers once again what what
that's going to look like aaron hasn't
made a decision russell's a seattle
seahawk there's nothing nothing change
in there
unless something's forced where he
doesn't show up in play but the bigger
conversation is uh and we had it a
little bit earlier around lamar jackson
and kyler murray both guys that
have extensions available to them and
kyler murray has come out blatantly and
said this is this is what i want this i
i need this this is the direction and
loyalty i need to be shown for for me to
really put it all in with what i need to
do here in arizona where on the other
side of this dakota decosta talks about
how he's waiting for lamar this is on
lamar's timeline if i'm lamar i'm like
go get that bag of money young man and
so what do you think about the two
dynamics here one with an agent one with
an overzealous agent but both in similar
situations
yeah no no doubt and and i think a
little
different you know on their career path
right now i think lamar jackson i mean
he's already he's already shown it i
mean being an mvp for a year showing
what he could do the ravens came in the
last season with a lot of guys injured
and but they were competitive through
the season until lamar jackson got hurt
so lamar jackson gives you a chance and
elevates those around him and that's
always the quality i look for he's a
likable guy he elevates those around him
he's a great team player guys in the
locker room love him he's going to get
his money and i think it is just
probably wait until lamar jackson and
his camp and i know it's kind of just
him um approach the ravens and try to
get the deal done and i think it's it
would be the smart thing to do i think
that's a no-brainer uh you look at kyla
murray i mean kyle murray had a
phenomenal year he's been doing some
good things you know arizona started off
hot but then he gets injured when he
comes back it doesn't look the same
and now you have a guy coming out with
his agent putting the statement out
there
to me
i just didn't like that approach you
know it seems like a lot of kind of
pelting in a sense give me my give me
what i deserve give me my money or i'm
going home like
and now i get it you know is he gonna
show up for five million dollars this
year i don't know and should he i don't
know he's done a phenomenal job he's a
good
um
piece to that team but i have more
concerns of the things we hear lingering
out there about his leadership and where
he is right now because that's what you
need going forward is the leader
to be a leader to elevate those around
you like we're talking about lamar
jackson so for kyler murray i i don't
know i i would kind of wait this out and
franchise him and see how this goes but
on the other side you know him and cliff
kingsbury shared the same agent cliff
kingsbury just got re-upped i could
imagine they're in talks with kyler
murray but it's just a tough decision to
make
um and i think you only know what you
want to do if you're in that
organization because you're around him
you see how the guys act around them and
if he's the guy for the
the future and you know that then i have
no problem handing out that bag of cash
but until then
maybe uh you wait another year or two
and let him prove himself once again
yeah i'm in agreement with you there
bruce grodkowski former nfl quarterback
11 year veteran uh pro football focus
analyst and with sirius xm
uh nfl radio as well uh the wide
receivers we watched them run last night
right the 40-yard dash and and chris
brockman and i here on the show were
kind of talking about it early on uh
when they run it they're on tv when and
and in person for you you watch the the
number go up on the board and taekwon
thornton goes 4.2
and everybody goes oh my god he just
broke the combine record and he's
probably thinking i dropped the mic i
you know i got a billion dollars in the
bank i'm jumping up to the first round
all this stuff and then you know an hour
later
it comes back out that that's it's not
that and and you've uh forfeited your
opportunity to run it again if he now
don't get me wrong four two eight is an
amazing fast speed but if you feel like
you can run faster and because you were
shown uh something that that really
wasn't real and you decide not to run
for a second time i mean that's that's
got to be diminishing
responses from from from players what is
your takeaway with that crystal lava
another one who ran a 429 and then was
ended up in the 439 area no absolutely
and you and i saw eye to eye on this one
i mean that that was disappointing last
night when we heard that because you do
get really excited if you're the player
and just like you said i mean now you're
like why why even run another one i just
broke the combine record i'm good i'm
done and then it comes back from a
4-2-1-4-2-8
but either way this guy can move i think
he has the production at baylor he he's
not a small guy either being 6-2 i think
that's the thing i like about him as
well so he definitely made a name for
himself he definitely maybe stepped up
the board a little bit more with his 40
but man you know what just think if
you're his agent too think we got one we
made it yes we we broke the record
and then to to find out you didn't but i
still think he did a great job and uh
you know give him a lot of credit for
putting in the hard work to be prepared
to run a fast 40. 428 still moving i
would love to know what that feels like
just like i told you last night i'd love
to know how it feels to throw the
football from ryan lee you know
me over here you know i got those little
lollipops going on i'd love to know what
it feels like to write for one like you
were able to do well uh you did pretty
good for yourself in fact i i want you
to tell a little bit of your story right
just you know and you talked about it
last night on the radio how
some of these players are made a name
for themselves have maybe um slipped
their slipped their note under the door
here for some of these general managers
crumbing one of them from kansas state
um brock purdy at iowa state that they
can take a look at and you get into an
organization right you get in in a fifth
sixth maybe even seventh round or even
as a free agent as long as you get on a
roster because
your situation you end up in tampa bay
with john gruden you learn an offense
and then chris sims goes down and you
you get thrust in and get to start what
11 games as a rookie i mean talk to us
about that in your story a little bit
through this process
no for sure a lot of times
all the players get caught up on when am
i going to get drafted but you have to
take a deep breath and take a back seat
and think look it's not so much when but
it's where you want to go to the right
situation and for me coming out in 06
man i wanted to get drafted as high as i
could i thought possibly in the third
round when i saw
um brody croyle going off the board and
charlie whitehurst and all these guys
going off the board i'm thinking i'm
next at any moment and i didn't go until
the sixth round but i went to tampa bay
and i remember my agent at the time
saying look this is a great spot because
you're gonna love you're gonna learn a
lot of good football and i did the first
minute i got there john gruden said
listen i want you to i want you to take
that blank or that cassette tape out of
your head that of football that you know
and i'm going to put a new tape of what
you're going to learn and you're going
to learn my you know new football and
good football and he did i learned so
much good football and he taught me
through ota's mini camp training camp
i had to learn with a sense of urgency
as if i was gonna be the starter and
with him coaching that way it made me
learn that way and i was thankful i did
because when chris sims went down third
or fourth week of the season
i was the backup and it was my time to
go in
and so i was prepared in the sense of
knowing the offense understanding what
to do
that i was ready for that moment but you
know as a rookie you live and learn you
have some good moments you have some not
so good moments you have to learn from
but that helped propel me to have an
11-year nfl career because of just such
a good foundation of learning football
the right way so when i see these guys
coming out
like a dustin crumb you know
the guys that even even the big guys
were talking about kenny pickett malik
willis where are these guys going to end
up going i want to be so anxious to go
so high in the first round let it unfold
if you go later in the first round if
you go second round it's not a bad thing
it's not when you go it's where you go i
think some of these quarterbacks are
going to end up having a really good
career
once it unfolds when we see who their
coaches who the system is and who
surrounds them because at the end of the
day that's a beautiful thing about
football it's the ultimate team game
give it tell us a little bit about how
how gruden got after sims because that
is that is historical stuff and i spent
some time down in tampa and i've heard
some stories but just kind of talk to us
a little bit about that
well you know i'll tell you what like
we're in training camp my rookie year
and gruden's getting after me and and i
feel like i'm like man i can't do
anything right sims is like
sims looks to me and he's like
no you have it easy you don't even know
how this guy was to me and i told you a
story last night though not not only so
much gruden but when you get in the nfl
i mean you have older veterans now
you're 21 22 years old coming into the
nfl you're around guys that are in their
30s yeah to have a family and kids and
this is this is their job i mean it's
not a it's not a game i mean it is a
game but it's a business
and i remember being in the huddle with
mike alstott joey galloway anthony beck
cadillac williams and i'm thinking to
myself i'm not getting in the huddle
and not going to be able to enunciate
these plays i have to know them like the
back of my hand because they were long
they were incredibly long
this one play they came kept me up at
night uh it was indie right pin x short
fake 96 power king naked left x slot
and i still know that to this day
because i could not sleep until i got
that right because i wasn't going into
the huddle and not gonna know how to
call this play when i had michael
pittman split out as a wide receiver
then i had to shift them back in the
backfield then i had to send the motion
i mean so there's a lot going on and
real quick another story uh i get in the
huddle at training camp
and there's this play green right west
93 week
can it with 96 power king so that's two
runs we called it in the huddle and i
called both runs to the right side i
said 92 weak cannon with 96 power king
we break the huddle i get to the line of
scrimmage and i start telling my whole
line oh no shoot it's 93 week it's 93
week
i turn back to tell mike alstott and he
grabs my face mask he goes which one is
it get it right
and you know he used maybe a little
different kind of language that way but
in that moment i was like oh man i can't
mess up a play yeah yeah i played with
mike too in tampa uh and with that crew
and i felt the same way right i got in
the huddle with keyshawn and
and uh
all starting work done and those guys
joey as well uh so yeah it's it's a
different world hey bruce thanks for
taking some time in and uh breaking it
all down for us
no for sure ryan thanks for having me on
it was good to be with you last night
today have a good week you too man have
a great weekend bruce gronkowski
everybody 11-year nfl veteran uh analyst
for the pro football focus as well as uh
siriusxm nfl radio hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here